ryan stelter over on cnn is he's really
sick of a different war not the war in
ukraine he's sick of the culture war you
know these republicans
these conservatives they just keep
pushing their ridiculous culture war
agenda such trivial issues don't matter
at all they're on the wrong side of
history you know those republicans they
don't even want to trans the kids
when the media calls it a culture war
battle
isn't that the wrong frame for this it's
not a culture war to talk about equal
rights for everybody in a country i mean
i guess it is but this is especially
when there's a real war raging in europe
i'm getting tired of the culture
warframe i'm getting tired this isn't a
culture why are we calling it a culture
war
we're just right that's what he's saying
right when when
the left and squishy republicans when
they come out and they say oh enough
with the culture war what they're saying
is give the radical left everything they
want
they never tell the left enough with the
culture war they never say hey left stop
killing all those babies and radically
redefining marriage and chopping up
people's bodies and transiting the kids
stop maybe stop doing that they never
it's only at the conservatives
who are not the belligerents in the
culture they're not the attackers in the
culture war
who started the culture war by
definition it's not the conservatives
the conservatives are trying to conserve
the old standards
it's the left that came in and said hey
we're going to completely change our
understanding of sex and human
relationships and family and marriage
and reproduction and babies and human
nature itself we're going to radically
change all of that and we're going to
let hulking husky dudes walk into the
girls changing room and if you have any
problem with that man i don't know you
got some weird hang up you're just a
crazy culture warrior enough with the
culture war just lie down and accept
what we tell you to do
no i don't think i will
i don't think i will
this issue seems to have broken through
in a way that marriage and some of the
other culture war issues in the past
have not this issue of transiting the
kids it has turned parents into a voting
bloc
parents who were liberal or independent
or
even
center-left they they have realized huh
i don't want little johnny to be told by
his first grade teacher that he's a
little jane
i'm going to vote against this crap but
that hubris i mean i guess this is the
running threat this hubris of the left
they're so confident of their own
ideology that in the long run their
ideology will prevail that no amount of
failure or human devastation will
convince them
this
otherwise this is true of of the sort of globalist
liberal establishment too you look at
the debacle in iraq the debacle in
afghanistan the debacle in egypt the
debacle in libya the very near i mean it
was a debacle in syria though it
actually could have gone worse
and
and after all of that
the
globalist adventurists will tell you
well it'll work next time they're still
so confident oh it didn't work because
of this oh this thing went wrong oh this
but don't worry my ideology of global
markets and peace and harmony and utopia
it's going to work next time let's do it
let's ratchet up the tension in in
ukraine it'll work it's
it's that are it's what you often hear
from the liberals right which is an
implicit
who cares if it works in practice does
it work
in theory
abortion leads to
horrible outcomes for everyone involved
and for society we've now got a dying
population you've got lots of depressed
women who have been in many ways duped
certainly enticed into committing this
horrible act you've got a million dead
babies a year almost 60 million dead
babies since roe versus weighed
and
and what
and they just keep doing it
marriage family totally collapsed poor
little kids now going on
cross-sex hormones mutilating their
bodies permanently disfiguring
themselves you look at all that carnage
they say no don't worry just a little
bit more of this it'll work next time
cut it out with your culture war saying
no to this no
no it's it's really easy for
conservatives to push back it takes a
little tiny bit of courage but
to overcome just the liberal
establishment but the people are on our
side here i get
the gop's fears of these things you saw
it with the letter that they wrote about
katanji jackson the supreme court
nominee they say don't uh just let this
one go through basically just don't get
too they're gonna call us racist hey
let's just cool it here okay guys just
no don't don't don't buy it don't give
them an inch they've gone so far their
views are so toxic we are doing so well
in the polls right now the people are so
disgusted by democrats failures on every
single issue keep
pushing conservatives stand your ground
[Music]